you think uh in the UK do you think more
houses in the UK should have like AC
yeah of course I every every shocks me
that you guys don't have AC yeah every
every house on earth should have one of
those heat pumps
um which is like the common uh those ACS
the ones that can cold and oh they're
way more effective than those giant like
um AC block things you see in America
yeah
um yeah I think every everywhere she had
them I mean I I think it makes way more
sense than having these because in the
UK we have these giant radiators
attached to like every room and these
these just giant metallic things that
just like heat throughout the room and
it's so inefficient and it's like can I
just have like one radiator like one
nice efficient thing that blows hot air
and then takes it out but obviously all
the houses in the UK were made before
um yeah because I was saying I was
thinking like now living in Japan with a
unit that can do both AC and heating I'm
just like white and dry and dry as well
I'm just like why is why is it so far
hard to find an AC unit in the UK
because what you know even if you'll use
it like one two weeks in the year when
we get that [ __ ] Heat Wave this like
the heat wave just seems to be getting
more and more and more extreme every
[ __ ] year and every year that goes by
I'm like yo people will need to like the
UK needs to start having at least some
kind of cooling unit because everyone's
gonna [ __ ] die like two weeks you
should fix a lot of things on a lot of
things everything everything actually
now I think about it just pretty much
everything yeah because I think modern
houses have it though like newer houses
yeah newer houses I'm sure have it but I
was I was shocked because I remember the
first time I went to the UK and I was a
[ __ ] place and that was during that
heat wave yeah right and it was like it
was night time and it was like what 30
degrees still and I'm like oh [ __ ] this
is like a Japanese summer night I'm like
oh all right I better turn the AC on and
I'm looking around for the remote in
God's room I'm like
where is it I think God's mom comes in
with the [ __ ] like old school like
fans here you go
that [ __ ] does nothing that's it that
just moves hot air around that does not
cool me down at all yeah that that is
the Southeast Asian experience yeah it's
we we just back at my grandma's house we
have fans which is like
even during the heat wave at least we
had fans because I know a lot of my
mates in the UK they didn't even have
fans I don't know how they [ __ ]
survived honestly I didn't have fans I
remember I was just suffering I remember
it's just awful but also isn't it is it
South Korea where leaving a fan on while
sleeping is like you'll die it's like a
Superstition is that crazy
and I swear on South Korea I think if
you leave the fan on while you're
sleeping you'll die
you just [ __ ] die oh I'm [ __ ] dead
then because yeah right since Sydney
needs a fan on at all times when she's
sleeping wait even when it's cold yeah
even when it's cold because it's because
of the noise it's it's like it's like
the
it's like comforting to her I guess I
don't like that like the the what is it
called the not White Noise White Noise
background background I was gonna say
background radiation that's not what I'm
saying radiation did you find anything I
just put a tub of uranium in my room
yeah if you run the fan with no open
windows it's an urban myth yeah well
well yeah I don't know why you're in
Hell guys I feel like I had this
conversation with Emily and Emily said
that to me yeah normally said it to me
or something in Japan I think it's like
if you sleep with the fan on or the AC
on yeah and you don't have like anything
to cover up your stomach then it's like
you know then my grandma's like oh you
catch a cold the AC demon will kill you
central air will come down and kill you
for me I don't know if this was a
Superstition but for me if you go to bed
with your if you go to sleep when your
hair still wet then you'll just wake up
with a cold oh dude everyone in Japan
says this yeah yeah my grandma and I'm
like bet I'm doing that just to spite
you and I because I I it's it's like
internal lies into me because I remember
I I was like my mom would always sell
this to me right if you go to if you're
too bad with your hair wet you're gonna
get a cold I'm like Batman I did it once
I got a cold so I was like [ __ ] mom was
right she knows huh is there any
scientific proof behind this I don't
know if there's any scientific proofs
maybe it's just like yeah if you had
really long hair I could be like oh well
yeah because it's not going to dry but
if you have like our hair yeah that [ __ ]
will dry in like 40 minutes dude I'm I
think it might just be like you know the
hair your hair gets cold when it's wet
and then that coldness just like gets to
your head yeah
I also heard an urban myth here that
some people were telling me like some
Japanese people they were like if you go
outside with wet hair you'll more likely
get like sick or get germs or some [ __ ]
because apparently it somehow keeps
germs or something I was like it's like
what the [ __ ] you talking about bro I'm
using the natural AC to dry my hair
also germs aren't that smart to be like
yo how moisture yeah I don't know any
any evidence behind this yeah they said
that it's not possible it's not possible
yeah you get a cold yeah okay well it's
like the urban myth where it's like if
you go out in the rain for too long then
you're gonna get a cold as well and I'm
like what where did these Urban myths
come from I guess well I think I think
actually if you are if your body's
actually colder you have way more chance
of getting sick yeah but then there are
some especially Japanese ones that just
don't make any sense like oh if you open
on an umbrella indoors then you're gonna
get struck by lightning oh and it's like
it's just bad luck if you do it yeah we
just have bad luck yeah it's just
unspecified bad luck in the in the west
issue clearly I'm like no God will
strike you down if you leave the
umbrella
you will be smighted every time I go
into an umbrella store I'm sweating I'm
like I want to see what this umbrella
looks like but I will be smited I see
people all the time leaving The
Umbrellas again it's just like an urban
you know legend or you know myth or
whatever it is yeah urban urban legend
people yeah
where you put it down
sorry yeah yeah yeah so you know like in
Japan there's the territory yeah where
you can you can stop the rain so in
Japan like as a kid uh you would do this
thing where you'd build it usually just
be like out of tissues or something but
it'd just be like a little snowman
looking thing and if it's it's raining
and you put it up on your windowsill
then the thing is that like the the next
day it'll be sunny you know just kind of
like a little thing that kids are taught
yeah there's an urban legend that if you
do that but if you hang it up upside
down then it's going to be raining the
next day and I'm like oh yeah I'm sure
I'm sure whether you know the weather is
just looking at being like all right how
many of them are [ __ ] time around
people just want to make their life more
interesting and that's that's how they
it's just this is just astrology with
extra steps I sort of swear to God like
yo yo what direction you're typing
oh you're probably a Libra
foreign
it's like
it's like you know you know the [ __ ]
men test but like they test like your
[ __ ] which which like specifications
like your nanas it's just it's just that
basically right except it's just
complete [ __ ] [ __ ] man if only if
only we had real men right yeah Omega
lives so much easier
yeah exactly exactly yeah where you're
facing North Carolina do you believe in
that feng shui [ __ ] no
I have a few friends who like [ __ ]
swear by it um like chakras and all that
[ __ ] too I'm like
all any of that it's like I'll be honest
I just don't believe in anything
straight up it's just nothing
I just don't believe I'm just here to
have fun clearly I hear Don't Stop
Believing I'm like bet
not you journey
is it is sometimes my life not that fun
yeah but like I you know it's just I
just love my life so do you do I get it
like because like do you do you do you
identify as a realist
or an atheist lots of realist I've never
heard of what is a realist like as the
name suggests it's just like you only
believe in things that are like
factually true true like scientifically
backed and just like things that are you
know I mean science grounded in reality
you know science science [ __ ] up a lot
um
a [ __ ]
they are they are step on a crack break
your mum's better who the [ __ ] made that
up that's [ __ ] quite frankly because
you're not coming with any other I
remember when I was eight and my friend
said that to me I was just like crap
crap
um you know I just think that for me it
seems like a lot of people who enjoy
that kind of stuff or like like talking
about it like um like the whole uh
what's the [ __ ] star sign [ __ ]
astrology yeah like that's just like
something fun for people to kind of feel
like they they kind of know people or
categorize people in a more of a
comforting way because the world is
scary if you think that everyone is just
like operating on their own and has no
kind of purpose yeah like I I think that
like dude I mean there's a lot of stuff
I don't understand and I don't think
it's because they're a [ __ ] Libra
[Music]
I don't subscribe to that notion of like
hey if I don't believe in this thing
neither should you I'm like hey if you
if you want to believe that because gone
is what are your cancer I'm a Gemini
actually what are you trying to say
you know I think he gives off cancer
energy he kind of did yeah every instant
player no I am not a cancer but if it's
fun if it's fun for you to hear like the
dance of Gemini and then kind of be like
oh yeah you can have it you know then
fine yeah whatever like that's I don't
give a [ __ ] no no I'm totally the same
it's like if you want to believe in it
you can believe in it but just don't
shove that [ __ ] down my throat yeah
don't don't like make me feel don't
demonize me weird for not believing yeah
and because you know you flipped a penny
four times that the the Zeus is going to
come down and jack you off like I just I
don't I'm not
I feel stuff like that they told me to
do that on the Cosmopolitan magazine so
uh I have to believe it you know I just
think people are bored and that's how
they keep themselves busy yeah people
people everyone's just distracting
themselves in one way or another people
be dumb I know I don't I don't think I'm
smarter than anyone else I just think
and I think a lot of people who know who
are like who like to talk about like say
star signs it's like they don't actually
like genuinely heart like deep down
believe in that [ __ ] A lot of people do
you'd be surprised there are some people
right I'm not saying that I'm smarter
than them because I don't it's like
there's some people who but I am saying
I am smarter though
whatever it's what you do like I I was
[ __ ] with a lot of things yeah that's
just one thing that I don't believe in
and I don't think that makes me better
than you or whatever that's why but
that's why I think just like it doesn't
matter what you believe in everyone
thinks everyone is dumber than everyone
else right so everyone thinks they're
smarter than they are as well there's
been like a bunch of studies where if
you ask people are you average above
average or whatever people normally say
like they're like above average yeah
which obviously doesn't make sense
if everyone is special no one is special
I believe Walt Disney said that I don't
know if that's true actually
I'm just I'm just quiet it was it was
Sun Tzu in the heart of the Art of War I
think who said that Vladimir Lenin
he said all your things